Russian bombs have damaged or destroyed  over 2 800 schools all across Ukraine  schools that are still accessible have  welcomed pupils from far away  but for many children this means a long  and sometimes dangerous commute the  first lady of Ukraine Orlando told me  about this program but families in  Ukraine are facing  but also about the anxiety of parents  when sending their children to school  we can do something about it  Ukrainian children need school buses so  Europe is now donating 14 million euros  for this  and of course we need more and this is  why the European commission is  organizing a solidarity campaign  donate school buses for Ukraine by early  2023  companies governments  and Regional authorities all across  Europe are invited to contribute the  European commission will cover the costs  to transport the buses to Ukraine  together we can help Ukrainian children  the future of Ukraine